I'm Leonard Engelmann the makeup artist
and hairstylist branch governor it's my
honor to be your host and on behalf of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences and the makeup artists and
hairstylists branch to welcome you to
the 85th Academy Award event and the
31st Oscar nomination for makeup and
hairstyling although hair stylists have
been included in the Oscar nominations
for many years this is the first year
the awards name is is stated as
achievement in makeup and hairstyling
this year Oscar celebrates the year in
makeup and hairstyling can also be seen
on our website at Oscars org so we
welcome hopefully viewers around the
world
the nominated films this year are
wonderful examples of the very vast
range that is the art of makeup and the
vast range of the selection process
within the makeup artist and hairstylist
branch our first film lay miserab is
recognized for makeup and hairstyling
for the entire film our second film
Hitchcock is recognized for the
transformation on Anthony Hopkins for
makeup and hairstyling our third film
The Hobbit an unexpected journey is
recognized for makeup and hairstyling
again for the entire film so we have
Leigh miserab Hitchcock The Hobbit an
unexpected journey we have a number of
people in the audience I'd like to
recognize these are past recipients and
winners of the Oscars
I'm going to ask you to please stand if
we can bring up the house lights please
stand and when I read your name and
please stay standing we have bill Corso
Michelle Burke Michael Westmore greg
cannom
you'll land a to sing
Deborah Lamia denaburg Howard Berger
Steve Laporte Lisa Westcott Tammy Lane
Trevor crowd Lynn Barber Beatrice de
Alba Christina Smith
Peter sward King and Martin Samuel
thank you
also I'd like to recognize some of the
cast's from the makeup television series
face-off
will you please stand okay we get the
house lights up goes on to face-off
and please watch on on Tuesday nights at
nine o'clock and you'll see some great
makeup and certainly a lot of drama also
I want to recognize from the makeup
artist and hairstylist Gil local 7:06
president suka Braille Ebert business
representative Tommy Cole and assistant
business representative Randy Sayer I'd
also like to thank the Academy's Mary
Rose McMann and her team for all of the
work and coordination for this entire
event it's a great job and a great
amount of work this is a wonderful time
for these eight nominees to bask in
their accomplishments and recognition
some of you in the audience may have
contributed to these films and should be
sharing in their glory so audience enjoy
enjoy this time applaud make noise
celebrate with these nominees because
that's what this is all about let's
start right now
today is a celebration of winners
every nominee that steps on this stage
is a winner every nominee tomorrow is a
winner
one film group will carry statues but
every nominee is a winner I'm very I was
very impressed a few years ago with
comments that now passed Academy
president Sid Ganis made at the Oscar
nomination luncheon and I'd like to
share some of those with you
the reason the Academy gives Academy
Awards is to honor and celebrate the art
of motion pictures it's why the Academy
exists the red carpet the press
attention the parties and the dresses
are all wonderful accessories to the
event but the Oscar exists to shine the
brightness all the brightness possible
of a light on you and your work the
Oscar exists because the founders
believed that movies were not just a
business and that people needed to be
reminded of that the Oscar exists to
tell the world that filmmaking is an art
and it's being practiced by some people
at a very high level and some of those
people are in the room today before we
hear from our Oscar nominees I'd like to
explain the process that brought us to
today in April
October and November the makeup artists
executive makeup artisan hair stylist
Executive Committee and the members meet
and as part of their business they
discuss the films that have been
released so far during that time of the
year and these are films that the
members feel should be seen by the other
makeup artist and hairstylist so this
list is then sent to all of the branch
members so they can be aware and
therefore as time goes along they can
continually recommend or not in December
all members were asked to attend a
meeting to vote for seven films that
will go on for consideration of
nomination these are selected as the
seven
best films for achievement in makeup and
hairstyling for the year I'd like to
point out how unbiased these selections
are as I read seventh the names of seven
films the 40 members in attendance chose
we have Hitchcock from Los Angeles we
have the Hobbit an unexpected journey
shot in New England
I'm sorry shot in New Zealand and
England we have Lee miserab shot in
England and France we have Lincoln shot
in Virginia we have looper shot in
Louisiana Shanghai and China we have men
in black shot in New York and we have
Snow White and the Huntsman shot in
England Scotland and Wales as you can
see seven great accomplishments in the
artistry of makeup and hairstyling
following this meeting the makeup
artists and hair stylists Executive
Committee meets and this is probably the
most difficult of the meetings because
the committee now has to choose a
maximum of two a possibility of three
for those most responsible for the look
of each film or character or characters
with a NH film that is being recognized
so it doesn't matter what the ads may
say it doesn't matter how much was spent
on advertising it doesn't matter what
someone has in their deal memo and it
doesn't matter what the film credits at
this point the executive committee has
to make the decision based on input and
the work that was done in 1986 prior to
there being a yearly Oscar for makeup
Planet of the Apes was going to receive
a special Academy Award there was to be
one statue that award as was the process
of the time would have gone to the
makeup department head of 20th Century
Fox dance tree peck dance said the
person most responsible for this
achievement is John Chambers and he must
receive that award
it's that standard of honesty and
responsibility that we follow today as
the committee painstakingly chooses the
individuals most responsible for what
has been recognized in each film the
first Saturday of January all members
were asked to attend a presentation by
makeup artists and hairstylists
recognized for these seven films this is
often referred to as the bake-off this
is when the final nominations were
chosen for the Academy Award for
achievement in makeup and hairstyling
for 2012 so as you can see the makeup
artists and hairstylists Academy members
spend a tremendous amount of unselfish
time in an effort to applaud the work of
others today we're going to see actually
how that process takes place I'm going
to ask each of the nominees to talk
about some of the work that took place
and what it is you'll see in the film
clips they represent will then show the
ten-minute clips of chosen segments from
their films so you can see this
wonderful work and the after the third
clip has been shown we will open the
floor for questions from the audience so
this then will be followed later on by a
wonderful reception downstairs in the
lobby
the motion picture industry is a global
industry today as you will see once
again as we introduce our nominees
please welcome for lay miserab Lisa
Westcott
we can bring the house lights up please
okay Lisa asking you to come up and take
a seat Lisa is credited as the makeup
and hair designer Lisa is joining us
from France this is the third Oscar
nomination for Lisa she was also
nominated for a Shakespeare in Love and
mrs. Brown two weeks ago she in England
she won the BAFTA Award for lay miserab
and we have Julie Darnell Julie is
credited as the makeup and hair artist
Julie if you'll come forward Julie joins
us from Germany where she is shooting
the grand Budapest hotel this is the
first Oscar nomination for Julie alright
this is uh this is a little time where
we're going to in a bit be showing some
some wonderful photos back behind here
and you'll get a great opportunity to
see some of the the work that was really
done by these two and and a very large
crew I'm sure okay the first photo that
we have we see Anne Hathaway a group of
the ladies this is towards the very
beginning of the film and you've got a
lot of work within this you want to just
describe some of this and there's a
question that I always love to ask it's
just their own hair or these wigs good
afternoon everybody and this there
wasn't you're absolutely right there was
a huge month work in all of these people
and towards the end of the and the scene
they all have hats off so all of them we
couldn't hide behind those great hats
that they were wearing for half the
scene so I would imagine three
but half of them had had wigs there was
all sorts of little details you know
there was we had one one person that was
blind
they have blind lenses but I'm not sure
you have a seal to saw that and and
other details that sadly you didn't see
but yeah I think after them yeah half of
them had the weeks and also their cause
they all had the teeth made no the these
so they looked stained and because you
didn't know which one was going to be
caught you know with them mouth wide
open so they all have these made that we
all look like having a costume so a lot
of detail that goes into this kind of
thing that we just sort of accept if
their teeth had been really bright white
but you look ridiculous
yeah and the whole thing I mean you need
one little thing not to be right and
you're blown you might look at home you
know everything has to now at some point
there had to be a decision made as to
with Anne Hathaway she's going to have
her hair cut on screen yeah and not real
well yeah okay so the decision had to be
is she gonna wear a wig it's gonna be
your own hair how did that come about
well to be absolutely Frank and honest
the decision was made way before I
started on the film what he was thought
of Miss with Anne's idea but she
discussed in the very early days and she
was meeting Tom Hooper she wanted a
haircut and it never it never we tried
actually to try and talk her out of it a
little bit because they were of course
we could do it not for real but she was
quite determined that she's gonna have a
haircut which is wonderful but but
because this was determined very early
on in the whole process then of course
the schedule was arranged accordingly so
yeah we'd have to pop you see yeah okay
well it was a great look you know
especially with her singing during the
period of time and such that her hair is
being cut and carrying on with the
emotion and everything
by the way Ann is going to be performing
tomorrow night the Academy Awards and
also for Best Supporting Actress so
you'll see here again there so here we
have her in this very short hair and
also
I'd like to just point out one thing at
the BAFTAs two weeks ago when she
received her her award she thanked her
makeup artists and hairstylists of Peter
Gooch Paul which Paul Gooch which I
thought was absolutely fabulous I always
love that I think she describes him as
an oasis of calm which just which is
perfect very calm okay now we see a
lady's hair cut here we're going to take
a look at some other ladies hair cuts
okay here we have Hugh Jackman and this
is quite a haircut we've got another
shot where we'll see the hair a little
bit more but I love the beard here and
do I remember is all of this beard his
or was there some attachment hair
extensions in I think he had about that
much growth a couple of inches so we
added to that with West's of hair and
then laid on hair as well and it had to
be permanent really to a point because
the first scene he's in water when
they're pulling the the boating is the
convict so it had to be waterproof and
it had to stay and it did now is that
one of those things where you start the
scene and you really have your fingers
crossed hard in hopes that that's all
going to work on machines they had waves
I mean it was you know really what's for
them and it didn't budge
say yeah that was good and it also had
the contact lenses yeah yeah that stayed
prosthetic scars stayed - which was
which we see the scars in this we see
that you know the really the the effect
of the the haircut very emotional effect
when you first see see him starting off
it was meant to be quite shocking yeah
you went on the base stringent diet as
well so between him and us and we all
kind of end up
this is kind of quite brutal look now
when you were starting to design and cut
the hair was it did you go in stages or
did you just go in there and you had
seen the concept drawings so yeah we had
discussed what we thought would look
great and he was all for it so it was
literally you know you've just got to be
brave and and go in and do it what we
have to do you know we did have the
concept drawings were crucial because
everybody could at least see where the
end you know where we were heading
so it wasn't that son of a shot in the
dark you know it was all on paper and
discussed and the director was extremely
involved as well very interested so it
was very much a team effort
really yeah we said to hew just go out
and buy a good hat okay now we move on
to much much later and we see Hugh
Jackman as the character is this is when
he's when he's ill yeah he's dying
yeah it's the end it's the end scene
really of Jean Valjean I think well in
that scene he does he sort of becomes a
ghost at the end I mean had some
different lenses made for him he's meant
to be dying of joy from being in the in
the sewers some lenses made that were
had yellow the whites were yellowed and
we gave him a white - all I just to kind
of dim his eyes a little really we had
green marble yeah we did I mean I quite
honestly we wanted to go further quite a
lot further
but the director didn't want us go any
further than this so we had to stop
there but I'd have liked to push it a
bit further now go from that to to
Amanda Seyfried and Eddie Redmayne and a
completely different look now in this
case there is a very much no makeup look
which sometimes can be more difficult
than than you know a heavier strong
makeup tell us a little bit about how
some of this came about what we what
what you were using or I mean Amanda is
very beautiful anyway so you've got a
good canvas to start with and I think it
was just really bringing out and
enhancing her beautiful features as they
were and just finding it you know a very
natural makeup base you know rather
rose-colored lips for that natural you
know it's really just enhancing what was
already there really I'm making sure
that had skin bounced yeah there was a
glow that she never do you have anything
you should never see anything so thank
you see it to the eye I think the eye is
the best to the eye it's you'll see I
can see them go might say I think is the
band this again is is that their own
hair or these wigs that they both yeah
yeah I mean Eddie had a great head of
hair so you could you know tongue it and
you know push it into
period shape and yeah so so it was
already there with Eddie he's amazing
here and Amanda was around here too so
for the wedding
the young Cosette the the young Amanda
the child that was a wig on but you
don't have a picture of her but they
know when you see her as a child for she
grows up okay that's what you teach on
all the posters that'll go uh and that's
a week now is this all her own hair yes
Tom wanted to make her dark and but that
didn't happen we didn't I didn't want to
so we had a discussion about Mendes
so because her mother was you know you
know Anne Hathway was dark it said so
doesn't matter
news why should the child be dark if
these with the mothers you didn't you
never need the father hmm
she ended up blonde okay then we come to
Helena Bonham Carter and a few of her
friends okay now this was an opportunity
to show off yeah yeah yes we took no
prisoners there I think the most oh yeah
that's the worst thing you can do is
just boring so we thought we'd be a
little showy there's not much
opportunity or name is really have a bit
of fun but the Shannara is where it was
really colorful and oh that their
conversions every time you saw them they
they look different all the time through
the film they I think they had three or
four different notes they had four
different looks but the fourth one that
it made I think ended up on the editing
room floor this was the first one and
yeah we obviously made many different
colors but that was affords a little bit
but she is just divine she's just magic
to work with okay and then our last one
we're gonna we're going to have any
looking a little bit more cleaned up so
we're not going to leave her too dirty
and such but you can see in this picture
more of the hair one of the things that
I said when we had the baked off that
those of you who are makeup artist and
hairstylist and that you you you cut
hair a lot of times on the set you'll
have different crew members who will say
eg you know would you have any time this
week to maybe cut my hair Julie didn't
have a lot of people coming up and
asking for haircuts
now I said I can only do one haircut and
that's it take it or leave it yeah so I
didn't have any I didn't have many
offers okay we're going to we're gonna
take a look at the 10-minute film clip
and thank you very much for coming up
here
I am Ichi but that form is called losing
him as a stair will do the boy to the
world
welcome
please Lumias Schober I'm here at your
commode with all the jutsu each
unjustice you know ha no man's beyond
our reach let all beware welcome sir
calm down alors I'm sure we hear in
common cause
can this be true I don't believe what I
see a man your age to be as strong as
you are
they think that man is me without a
second glance the stranger they are
found this man could be my chance why
should I save his hide why should i
right there is wrong and I have come so
far and struggled for so long dear
Cosette if such a lonely child how
pensive how sad you seem to me believe
me my power I feel how quiet it must be
I can see with all
he is
bring him
take me now take me there
bring me
breathe wakey-wakey
we're opening pages and they crawl out
on all fours thank you darling I used to
dream that's how you with my sad friends
have you seen what's happened since you
were laughs a job to fondant he's no
seems to me it's the child stole for me
yeah
join your sister legs only in your sleep
surely not you've got that's right
dearie
but that voice
beautiful work some of the names of the
makeup artist and hairstylist that were
involved in La Mesa Rob are listed in
your program you can take a look at now
please welcome for Hitchcock Howard
Berger Howard is credited as the special
makeup effects artist he is joining us
here technically from Los Angeles but
actually he flew in from New York he
worked all day yesterday took a red-eye
in from New York and got here at 9:30
this morning and he's looking forward to
actually sleeping tonight the his lab is
presently working and continually
working on the walking dead he recently
finished the lone survivor and is
preparing for a department head for the
amazing spider-man 2 which will be shot
in New York this is the second Oscar
nomination for Howard he was also
nominated for the chronicles of the
Narnia Chronicles of Narnia The Lion the
Witch and the Wardrobe of which he went
in Oscar
and we have Peter Montaigne Peter is
credited as special makeup effects
artist Peter is joining us from Los
Angeles he actually came in yesterday
from New York and it's recently
completed filming of the lone survivor
and will also be on the amazing
spider-man 2 this this is the first
Oscar nomination for Peter and we have
Martin Samuels Martin is credit this
department head hair this is the third
Oscar nomination for Martin he was also
nominated for Pirates of the Caribbean
at World's End and Pirates of the
Caribbean curse of the Black Pearl and
Howard I believe you have a special
guest that is going to jail I do have a
special guest I was really lucky to one
work with this magnificent person on on
Hitchcock and and then I was lucky
enough to to get him to come in and say
hi to everybody but I want to bring up
our director Sacha gavazzi please
also I just want to say I flew in from
Cape mentally me Sasha also directed on
this great movie called anvil the story
of anvil if you guys have ever seen it
it's great and if you haven't you should
rent it tonight because it's spectacular
thank you how it very true yeah okay we
start off with somebody who I think we
recognize through the decades of mr.
Alfred Hitchcock I have to call him mr.
Alfred Hitchcock because I actually did
a picture with him and he was always
referred to as mr. Hitchcock now here we
have Sasha in action I'd had a lot of
coffee please
but I think it captures the makeup
brilliantly ed Gein's basement and and
just you know the way the way we
approaches Sasha I had met Sasha through
Peter Dinklage who's who's a fantastic
actor he's on Game of Thrones and Sasha
had was doing another project with Pete
and and I did a couple test makeups and
then all of a sudden out of the blue I
got a phone call I'm in the airport in
Michigan I'm heading back from Oz and so
it's March 3rd or March 8th
yeah which opens March 8th uh and thanks
Peter
and shameless shameless and it's Sascha
on the phone and Sascha says I've got a
Tony Hopkins here with me did you mind
if we put you on speaker and I'm
thinking oh my goodness I'm gonna talk
to Tony Hawkins this is pretty amazing
so anyhow it was a great conversation
and we we talked about the film and the
potential of this movie and and what it
would take and I felt confident that we
could certainly come up with something
that that would work and you know as the
as the project developed we finally got
the green light and you know we fought
for X amount of weeks to do test makeups
which was really really important and
you know Tony was on board which is
number one and I'm sure a lot of you out
there sometimes you if you get an
opportunity to do test makeup sometimes
it's not always on your your actor
sometimes you're doing
Tass on on doubles and it's just never
the same but Sasha really fought for us
to to do this with Tony and Tony did as
well and and you know through a series
of different makeups and and sculptures
and and we'll see in a little bit but
Richie Alonso was was Mikey sculptors
Ritchie me stand up Ritchie Ritchie
cheesecake Ritchie I know you're out
there is well done Richard Ritchie's
great and and and actually it's it's
Peter calls Ritchie the secret weapon
which is true because Ritchie can do
anything in the universe he's truly
amazing you know and there's there's the
great Ritchie Alonso now I love this
picture because this is the only time in
any picture that you will ever see the
edges of this appliance right now Sasha
when you start off with something like
this I I think there was dialogue before
that that at one point you were looking
at a complete duplication well I think
it was we went through an interesting
process because clearly he has such a
specific you know incredibly particular
look that we went through the whole
process so we thought we actually they
did a makeup where Tony Hopkins looked
exactly like Alfred Hitchcock and it was
wonderful except no one knew it was Tony
Hopkins I mean I could have been doing
it so it was this weird thing where you
know because there was a sort of a
mischief and an irony to the film it was
important that the audience both got the
sense of a Hitchcock but also had a
sense that it was Anthony Hopkins
playing this incredible man and so we
tried to I think you know quite well
fine find the balance between you know
Tony playing Alfred Hitchcock and
clearly you know how it calls it a
portrait I think it is you know he was
very much channeling it so we weren't
really trying to do an impersonation we
were just trying to do Tony's version of
hitch and I think we came out in exactly
the right place I think so absolutely
and and and you know what's also cool is
I mean I'm very very lucky to have you
know be a cone owner of cane the effects
group because without all that brilliant
artists that work at K&B I've been
I wouldn't look as good as I do you know
and and there's a there's a lot of my
thinker here actually if I can take a
sit can you guys hey any K&B guys stand
up let's get some candy guys there we go
hello candy
so this Mike Mike Ross over there and
rich me very rich painted everything on
the show and Mike molded get all the
mall dwarf Joe's up there so yeah so
these guys I really do feel this way you
know and it's same with you know when
you're working on a film you know your
your crew is is is really what is behind
you and I was very lucky because I had
amazing resourceful guys that are great
artists and great great skilled
technicians and and really helped
troubleshoot these these makeup so that
they were a hundred percent every single
day and Derek kraut ran all the silicone
for us who never ever fails and and yeah
and a huge part of the the picture also
it's the incredible melt in Samuel I'm
sure many of you know and I've known
Martin a long long time and and and when
I had the opportunity to direct a film
for the first time this is my sort of
first narrative film I I wanted to get
the most brilliant people in the world
and I just want to say to them thank you
so much for doing this for all of you
guys I got really lucky out Sasha when
when you have an actor who is
transformed like this what's the first
few days that you're working is there
sort of the strange feeling of I saw
this I saw one man go in the door and
then I saw another man come out the door
how is it from well I mean it yes it was
it was it was exactly that was very
weird when when finally we sort of
arrived at the makeup tony would come in
in the morning and you know Howard at
Peter and Martin would do their thing
and he would step out of the room and it
was just and he would he took delight
Tony and coming up to people
particularly who hadn't seen him as
Hitchcock and tap coming up behind them
and tapping them on the shoulder and
going good evening you know and people
would jump you know because it was
really eerie and the best one actually I
was there when Helen Mirren actually saw
Tony for the first time and she went
what the bleep like I won't say but
which is quite something coming from
Helen Mirren but she was genuinely
shocked because it was such an
incredibly sort of Center it was just
you really felt hitch
right there and the the warmth and the
humor as well as of course the the
craziness and the madness of Johnny but
he sort of was able to it was quite
disturbing in a in a you wouldn't leave
the trailer and I see was completely
made up like they call him for rehearsal
and he would not leave unless he was
dressed as we do not go unless he was
completely 100% and that and the
greatest part of the day was at the end
because obviously it took quite some
time about an hour and a half I think
each morning to get him ready
but then the makeup would come off in
two seconds and Tony took great delight
in ripping into his prosthetics and come
out the first now it was very surreal
because the crew guys were like oh my
god he doesn't like to do Hannibal
Lecter just in case people know he does
do it almost all the time
at a certain point you have to say Tony
can we just chill it with the Hannibal
stuff and he would do it every night was
very funny I would I would imagine the
crew day after day were amazed at seeing
this transformation well they only saw
him for like four what did in the whole
shoot I think they only saw Tony Hopkins
like four hours the rest of it was all
Hitchcock we only saw of Tony's for like
yeah I mean Tony would basically Tony
would come in in the morning and and you
know Martin had already shaved the top
of tony's tony's head tony has uh you
know a nice head of hair so Martin cut
you know shaved this and cut in color
Tony's hair and he would come in in the
morning and and we would do Peter and I
would start and there was a horseshoe
piece a big horseshoe piece and nose tip
and ear lobes and there's and and yeah
the flashing was room nose no it wasn't
quite yes the nose doesn't finish there
but that's a good good example and then
you know we'd paint them and and used a
lot of math makeup on on this actually
and then Martin would come in and Martin
would then glue the little lace piece
the lace piece on top there's Martin
shave his head every day and then
colored in and bled these his own white
sides out into the hair and then laid a
little thought toupee on the top just to
give that sort of right wispy balding
effects that he wasn't sort of
completely clean-shaven on
top of his head and then and then what
beautifully
yeah it did a work gray and then it was
just nice even so we had this really
great room we at the studio we shot and
we just all it all happened there and
then Joey Weiss who is our brilliant
costume designer would come and Julie
would come in she stops just like that
and she put Tony into the fat suit in
the and his costume again like what Pete
was just saying that Tony would not
leave the room until he was a hundred
percent and it wasn't like we you know
Sasha and all of us had to call him you
know hello mr. Hitchcock how are you it
was it just was he didn't want to break
the illusion you know he wanted to keep
it going and didn't want to like come to
set without the fat suit on and be like
you know oh hey it's Tony with just a
makeup on or you know he really wanted
to keep it alive and and he did and and
that and that's you know that's a big
reason why also I feel it's a success
it's it's a partnership amongst all of
us including Tony you know you we we do
a makeup you know Martin Peter and
myself brings X amount to the table and
then Tony brings the rest you know and
brings that makeup to life and he was as
invested as we were and it was very he
was very available he made him see who's
really into the part and he had
mentioned something to us about he had
met Hitchcock many years ago it was at a
restaurant and he's his his manager had
introduced him to him and one of the
things he told me about that he noticed
about his face was that he had a lot of
little capillaries he had a lot of these
fine little broken blood vessels all
over his face so he said could you could
you do that
could you incorporate that into the
makeup and I said yeah sure whatever you
want so I spent a good amount of time
with a very fine little brush painting
in all these little veins and until he
felt it was the way it looked the way
when he had met Hitchcock so he was very
happy good so he was here too he had a
lot of input into the into this
character which was great for us I think
one of the great moments for us was when
obviously we were making this film and
we're recreating Alfred Hitchcock but an
amazing moment for us was when Marshall
shlong who had been the original script
supervisor on psycho who's about 83 a
wonderful gentleman decided to come to
the set and the first time he saw Tony
he just stopped his heart stopped he
just and he watched the scene and you
know his his memory is not what it once
was but after he watched the scene
actually I think on that day that we
shot in the basement
he came up to to Tony and he had tears
in his eyes and he said you know you've
given me my memories back you know that
for us was at the moment where we were
like okay we're making this film but
actually this is these the people who
were there were just it was just a
beautiful sort of I think acknowledgment
also have your incredible work and and
and it was just a wonderful a wonderful
moment and also Hilton Greene had been
the first ad on psycho and so many
people who work with Hitchcock came to
visit and that was a that was a great
part of the story for us and Martin
wanted you I mean you know Pete and I
and the three of us handled the
Hitchcock make like you handled the
entire hair department yeah the entire
hair department
it wasn't much to do was
transformational transformations of
Jessica Biel which was very exciting as
she's such a contemporary looking girl
to turn her into Vera miles have Lyra
Mars looked in psycho so that was all
wigs and scarlet johansson and also jess
Toni Colette and of course Dame Helen
Mirren transfer transforming her into
Alan Ravel they all wore wigs and and we
had a terrific to really a bunch of
makeup and hair stylists also Lily
Hewitt did he make up did it was amazing
makeup really an amazing she captured
that era just absolutely beautifully
Julie and I worked together in the
trailer and then I'd go in every morning
to Peter and how its trailer to do
Anthony it was a very extensive hair and
makeup show
and it was a wonderful set and a
wonderful reconstruction of the original
psycho and the original things that
happened on a day to day basis in their
household of Hitchcock's
it was it was a beautiful film and we
owe everything to our director Sacha
Gervasi Martin I think I know that you
have a number of wigs down there and I
think you also have the the hairpiece
that you put on yeah Anthony Hopkins
correct there are some very nice weeks
that we used on scarlet on Jessica and
on Helen on the display and also the
hairless toupee that we used on Anthony
yes you'll see a wonderful display of
all of the films downstairs in the lobby
and a number of things that have been
brought in and one of the most
impressive things that you will see is
Alfred Hitchcock standing next to a
table the full size and when you go up
to him you will swear that he's alive
it's actually Tony it just possibly he
said can we do a sequel and that wasn't
the sequel to okay so here we see put
together wearing a hat he's working out
in the yard here and then our last shot
is the crew what we what we did is um
Tony we introduced Tony to time-lapse
photography so we set up a bunch of
GoPros and I had a 5d and we would shoot
we would shoot time-lapse is all the
time and then cut them together during
lunch and then Tony would take great
Glee at seeing how fast it all came
together and what have you and so that's
the crew obviously myself and Martin and
Peter and and that's Ken ken was Tony's
dresser and assistant costume designer
Anna was Tony's assistant and then
Christina Gonzalez handled our lenses on
the film cuz Tony wore brown lenses and
that was a shot we set it up you know we
had to take photos of us goofing off and
we even did a time-lapse of Tony taking
his makeup off one day when I think we
cut that to the psycho music and he
starts off by taking a pair of scissors
and stabbing so he was just so into
doing
that it just made our job so much more
fun because you know sometimes you get
an actor he's not really into it and
he's very aloof he does want it you just
want makeup doesn't like makeup but Tony
just loved makeup he loved what it did
and it was just made it so much that
much yeah and I think you know when you
work on a film I always feel that it
always starts at the top and and Sasha
was the very top and and it really you
know every day Sasha was in a great mood
always treated everybody with respect on
the point you know beyond belief because
it was a big day was almost a TV
schedule you know thirty five days and
so much to shoot and Sasha knew exactly
what he had it do and so there's no
reason for anybody to be unhappy or or
come you know have complaints because
Sasha was corrected that shows what he
wants I have your check it all trickle
down and it was just a you know it was
great you know I mean we were lucky we
were shooting in LA we got very lucky
with the actors we had Anthony Hopkins
and Helen Mirren and you know and and
and and how was talking about Tony's
commitment to the part you know we would
we would have one-line parts and Tony
Hopkins would show up in the morning and
read with the actors so it was quite an
experience for them - oh my god I'm
reading with Tony Hawkins you know if
that was the attitude and the spirit on
the film great we're gonna go ahead and
see our film clip I'm gonna ask the
nominees to take seats in the front here
and please please think Sasha for
joining us here it's wonderful
oh good evening
but brother has been killing brother
since Cain and Abel and even I didn't
see that coming I was as blindsided as
poor out Henry down there and apparently
the authorities shared my naivete in
other words they believed the young
man's story that Henry fell hit his head
on the stone and died of smoke
asphyxiation on the other hand if they
hadn't believed him
Ed Gein would never have had the
opportunity to commit those heinous
crimes for which he became most famous
and we of course well we wouldn't have
did you read that little snippet from IH
Wireless review in The New York Times he
said he found the climax to be overdraw
yes well I don't mr. Wilders had a
climax in years North by Northwest their
minds us of mr. Hitchcock's earlier more
inventive spy thrillers and there was an
accompanying list that expensive stars
to pretty it up Fox is offering you the
Diary of Anne Frank for the third time
the audience would spend the entire
picture waiting for miss Frank to
discover the corpse I'd hidden in the
Attic
wouldn't you agree Nancy r/c MGM looks
you for the Ian Fleming book see no
Royale a Cary Grant
definitely or Stan doesn't you know I
just made that both it was called North
by Northwest and Starr my dear is mere
self-plagiarism from schools nice clean
nasty little piece of book that's what
I'm looking for
I've seen happier faces on a school bus
going over a cliff will you be making
jobs then everyone in Hollywood resents
me I make the millions of dollars and
every year I sent it does dreadful of
all shouting us waiting for someone just
to say you're good mr. Hitchcock we're
ready for you on set mr. Hitchcock
I'll be there in a moment where's your
driver I've been asking myself the same
thing well I can give you a ride if
you'd like oh my god what a tiny car
candy corn girls love them I nicked them
from Tony's dressing oh I thought you
only liked those Fauchon chocolates our
needs must from the DevilDriver idea
luckily I'm driving thank you forgot to
look in the bathroom
and like you're missing the vital clue
like that what you mean
my mother always said if you want to do
a job good right
yes sir
you still think you're just riding
together
you cannot do about it
it's my favorite place just shut the
door make the world go away don't you
ever get lonely not here
it always talked to my mother
that's my mother that's my
we're no darling this could be the
biggest success of your career you know
mama I will never there be a find a
Hitchcock blonde
I've waited 30 years to hear you say
that
and that my dear is why they call me the
master of suspense
and so gentle viewers psycho turned out
to be one of my greatest achievements
and armor and I got to keep the house
and the swimming pool but you know what
they say in Hollywood you're only as
good as your last picture so if you'll
excuse me I had better total away to
begin the exhaustive search for my next
project unfortunately I find myself once
again quite bereft of any inspiration
however I do hope something comes along
soon good evening
in your program is a list of the makeup
artists hairstylist and various
technicians involved in Hitchcock next
we have the Hobbit an unexpected journey
please welcome Peter Swartz King Peter
is credited as the makeup designer Peter
joins us from England and he'll soon be
returning to New England to finish work
on the other two hobbits this is the
second Oscar nomination for Peter he won
an Oscar for Lord of the Rings The
Return of the King and we have Rick
finletter Rick is credited as the key
makeup artist and hair supervisor Rick
joins us from Australia will soon be
returning to New Zealand where he also
will be working on to the next two
hobbits this is the first Oscar
nomination for Rick
and Tammy Lane Tammy is credited as the
prosthetic supervisor Tammy joins us
from Los Angeles and she also will be
returning to New Zealand to work her
finished working on the other two
hobbits this is a second Oscar
nomination for Tammy she was also
nominated and won for Chronicles of
Narnia The Lion the Witch and the
Wardrobe and Peter I believe that you
have a special guest for us here today -
yes we do
I'd like to introduce Thorens right-hand
man the man who always acted first and
ask questions later
the actor gran McTavish who played
Dwalin
well we have a big accomplishment here I
want to I want to start off by just by
bringing up our first picture here
here's a great shot of completed wharfs
and and we also see Graham here in full
costume full wardrobe certainly
different looking than then he looks
sitting next to me here he's well rested
Graham can you just describe what what
your makeup is here well yeah that um
that's obviously me getting my pickup
call for tomorrow I think that's that's
my look no I had three pieces for the
the makeup I had a foam cap and then a
silicon cap and then a piece for the the
nose and the the bridge there that was
that was the make him that took about
well we got it down to an hour just over
an hour which was pretty good
they were very slick by the end I have
to say and then the hair was six
separate pieces actually they were
applied that took about 40 45 minutes
and then it was the costume after that
but it was it was an interesting process
going in and then the first time
especially for me when we all got
together and we got to see each other in
all our makeup it was like seeing people
just disappearing into a room and then
coming out as completely different
people it was remarkable now I believe
also Peter and we see part of it here
too because these were supposed to be
Dwarfs and because they were supposed to
be or because they were actually
normal-sized people you had to give them
more of the the physical structure of
dwarfs that's true I mean what we tried
to do I think you'll agree is we tried
you know you're trying to these guys are
meant to be four foot high four foot to
something like that and you know a lot
of them
- and quite slim and so to try and
achieve the fact that these guys look
like towards we had to physically sort
of squash them and why do them widen
them so you could do that with the
costume widen up so what we try to do
with the makeup I think you'll agree to
me was to try and sort of lose their
necks we tried to lose next we try to
widen it with hair which might to do all
that stuff yeah that was the reason why
he asked of a foam cap and a silicon cap
the phone caps were worn there all
different sizes for each of the
characters and actually Dwalin x' cap
was the smallest not because you have a
big head honey though but um it was - we
had to accentuate some of the features -
like to you know to create this illusion
that we were all trying to create with
the hair so the we enlarged their heads
and widened their ear spanned and
broadened their foreheads and enlarged
their noses to kind of create this squat
squat hm yeah because we actually
lowered their is down as well so there
is four sort of near their shoulders
again to try and achieve that but losing
their neck so you ended up with them
like that rather than being nice to all
elegant humans and a tremendous amount
of wigs tremendous amount of facial hair
yeah everyone in this film is wigged
there's no one with their own hair even
when we get down to extras and stuff I
reckon 85% a wig but all the actors had
to have no one no but you could no I
could grow the face shot or anything
like that so everything had to be stuck
on yeah just bring it up to you walls
and walls rooms and rooms week speeds
eyebrows the whole thing was just an
incredible sight to see to walk into
every morning because the thing we had
to do of course we had the actor with
the wig we then know how to have a scale
double with the wig and the beard and
ascetics and everything then we now have
to have a stunt double
with the wig the beard the settings and
everything else as well and then there
were other doubles coming in I mean the
the actual 13 tours they
the each character had six weeks and
eight beards times thirteen and that was
thirteen and then all the other actors
had at least the their characters had at
least three weeks and any facial network
through it because we had to sort of do
this whole scale thing and we were quite
lucky but we had one guy who played
nearly all the tall scales
tall Paul till Paul played everyone he
had the biggest arrange of weeks of
anyone I've ever known it's fantastic
now looking at Graham back here it looks
like Graham has a great set of eyebrows
on there too Yeah right yeah that was
the most painstaking thing of the makeup
for the prep wise for the prosthetics
Department 11 of the 13 dwarves wore
these t pieces that were silicon for
heads and noses combined and so in doing
that we had to add in their eyebrows and
since we're shooting on 48 frames HD
epic red camera system and all that I
didn't feel lace pieces would be good
enough for you know you know for that
type of thing to get the real close-ups
and so we painstakingly hair punched
every set of eyebrows for everyday 266
and Counting days you're going they
never say wait wait until you were you
hear what else they hair punched yes so
I mean the only the only dwarves that
did not have punched eyebrows were kilee
and fili
now what about hands and legs and feet
oh yeah well in order to create the
illusion we had to because once they
were in their costumes and wigs and and
full makeup their hands look really tiny
so what a who manufactured all of our
prosthetics also manufactured these
lovely gloves and arms that the dwarves
also wore so not only were they made up
and on the head they were wearing
silicone hands and arms in same way with
Bilbo with his Hobbit feet were pull-on
and
and like dwellings arms you know he he's
want his arms are exposed the entire
movie and so we had to hair punch all
all of his hair and every time those
arms came on and off hair would no
matter how carefully those the hair
would come out and so we'd have to
painstakingly reaped all the hair back
into these arms and we had a a team I
had a team doing that on a rotation so
it's not just the face well we see here
you know another group and then we this
is the first time that we see Ian
McLellan as Gandalf in in our clips here
but then great big beard on this that
looks like a lot of weight to carry how
did how did you handle that Rick his bid
wasn't so bad I mean some of the dwarfs
beards were infinitely heavier than his
yeah problem with Ian's beer don't get
caught in everything so when he got
dressed you know or undressed it it
either pull it on or it'll pull it off
or pull it to the side or wind machines
that have it spit in the middle and he
looked like some weird I don't know what
billion was always very patient with it
completely he'd always let you do your
job and get it ready and get it
camera-ready so yeah but I mean it was
with some of the dwarf beards was so
heavy because after we had them knotted
you couldn't actually not anymore my
hair in them so then we had to add Wes
to them and so for to get this bulk but
if we just stuck them on they would have
fallen off within five minutes so we had
to do a very very very old-fashioned
thing and we used to actually stick
straps on the side and so before we put
the wig on we put the beard on and we
stick with straps at the top of their
head and then we put the wig on and let
the straps take some of the weight
because otherwise it would have been
impossible yeah what were you using is
the the adhesives for the hair work I
can't remember anything lying around I
think wasn't it
anything that was sticky was good
Ben is using Ben Nye spirit gum yep
which strangely enough reacts very well
with baldies like it really adheres at
least to the point that used to become a
problem at night trying to get it off
because the moment it would retouch it
would read here itself so you kind of
have to get in and lift it get something
else you know the underneath that lifts
it again and it sometimes it was a
two-person operation yeah but this was
just basically spirit gum okay all right
then we go to a completely different
look here now with Kate Blanchet yeah
the only woman in the whole thing you
should have seen tall Paul in that
costume yeah exactly yeah no she was
fine she was fantastic wait wait I mean
she is you know and everyone says always
an amazing job but you know she's quite
amazing in the first place so and she so
loved going to sleep when you were doing
her makeup so she was absolutely
gorgeous in this I anytime I see Kate
Blanchet I can't help but think of the
Curious Case of Benjamin buttons when
she was in her her later ages and then
also in the hospital you know and I
think of that character and I look at at
this and I think you know beautiful work
beautiful work Peter Kay thank you yeah
it was the same week that we had to use
the wig that we used before because we
couldn't get any more hair long enough
to make anything new for us so we had to
use the same old one it just doesn't
exist anymore okay and here Tammy we've
got you with the working a little magic
here yeah just just kind of touching him
up he was uh he was a extremely hot a
lot of these guys get extremely hot so
keeping these prosthetics and beards and
wigs on was tenuous you had to stand by
and of course these silicon pieces were
the blends where the when they get hot
they get these lovely sweat bubbles
is what we call this grandma yes way
they used to come and basically milk me
they would they would milk my brows and
sometimes they'd milk my arms and it was
when it was it was not so bad for me it
was pretty unpleasant for them I can
tell you yeah especially when they had
some trajectory trajectory yes when they
would pull my arms off at the end of the
day if I'd been fighting in the arms
that the combination of the sweat and
the talc and everything like that inside
created this really extraordinary
mixture that and that the violence of
the pulling off of the arm would result
in this sort of spray all around me it
was yeah we got to know each other very
well the same thing happened with Martin
Freeman's feet and now you did not want
to be around that and now I love this
picture and the caption for this picture
is I said follow me but you can see what
I mean about the behavior with the sound
guys getting in underneath it and
everything it was just thank goodness
that was a McKellen wearing it's crazy
it's a wig I'm a sound guy - yes -
someone else everyone had to wear wigs
yeah also you can see in their portals
they're the green-screen and you know
there was a tremendous amount of green
screen and particularly in this sequence
where you saw just you know gorgeous
atmosphere outside there and mountains
and everything else which actually was
you know coming from the green screen
yeah that's right I mean they did have
actually just talking about how quickly
they had this from this crew working for
about nine months just going out in the
helicopters and that shooting skies and
other scenery and God knows what else to
replace on this green-screen it was
amazing and here we have the whole group
all in one and you can see all the
intricacies of the
the makeup the the beards the wigs all
of the prosthetic
great wardrobe you know some tremendous
creations of characters for this
situation yeah I guess when we did Bamba
and he's big we used to call that beard
the strangler that big orange thing but
you know again you had we had to be
practical we're gonna be shooting for
nearly two years on this thing and so
that actual that part of the beard what
used to be carried over someone's
shoulder and then only when we were
about to go for a take was he actually
hooked on when the rest of the hair was
tucked in otherwise I mean it would have
been possible to have worn that all day
long every day for 16 months yeah I
remember one of the strangest directives
Peter and I took at the beginning was um
Peter Jackson wanted Harlan's beard to
be shaped like a bell you can't cut the
shape in because it doesn't stay so we
labored over that for weeks weeks weeks
try to get it shape and he kept saying
no no do it again I have to say about
the process of getting all the guys to
this stage was it was a long process of
many months from concept drawings to
actually finally Peter Jackson and
overall the producer not being happy
with what we've done
we'd go show until after show-and-tell
to change stuff to change the hair lines
change some of the hair to change
prosthetic to change whatever it went on
and on and that went on through the
whole film once we got the 13 drawers
down we then if the drawers had a
different look or whatever there would
be draggled or whatever we do a show
tell again so we did hundreds and
hundreds of showin tells but every
character and we they would not go in
front of the camera until Peter and
everyone was happy with what they look
like well we're going to take a look at
the the film clip here now and we're
going to have our panelists go down to
the front row here let's congratulate
them and thank you very much Grand Prix
for joining us in the contribution far
to the east over ranges and rivers lies
a single solitary peak the dwarves are
determined to reclaim their homeland I
like visitors as much as the next Hobbit
I'd like to know them before they come
visiting mr. Baggins yes sir I'm
surrounded by dwarves what are they
doing so this is the Hobbit you asked me
to find the 14th member of this company
and I have chosen mr. Baggins me no
comparison seen by most if they choose
which gives us a distinct advantage
we'll seize this chance to take back
Erebor
Mithrandir why the halfling hi Bilbo
Baggins
just because I'm afraid so this is your
purpose to enter the mountain what of it
there are some who deem it wise
a dark part has found a way back into
the world why don't we have a game of
riddles loses precious favorites it
I would take each and every one of these
dwarves over the mightiest army
loyalty honor a willing heart I can ask
no more than that
homes now behind the world
all right quite a group huh okay who do
we have with our first question
okay I'll break the ice right there we
have somebody over here with the
question hi my name is j q hi Leonard
I actually had a question for Tammy that
I asked her at IMATS but once I heard
about the spirit gum and the baldies I
have to ask it again uh Leonard taught
me how to lave beards and so I have a
huge interest in I know that Tammy was a
prosthetics supervisor for this but I do
want to know did you guys just slap the
baldies on their skin yeah when you put
it down for the hair pieces well I'll
take that too Rick sorry I was actually
referring to the UM lice pieces going
over the appliances that's where I was
confused because you guys were saying
that you use baldies in spirit gum and
you had issues removing it so I'm like
what trick is this baldies and spirit
gum that I haven't known we did on
occasion though apply it directly to the
skin in a very well ventilated area with
no problem whatsoever and the removal
was quite fast and the adherence e is
simply amazing
great thank you welcome I take you
another question I have the microphone
so um this one's for Howard for
Hitchcock did you run into a lot of
problems with Anthony Hopkins sweating
and it did that affect the makeup at all
when you ran into it yeah I mean it's
it's similar like what Tam was talking
about and Peter and Rick about milking
your actor and you know there's times we
you know Tony would work the full day
you know between 12 to 14 hours and it
was doing you know it's starting to get
warm and and we get like little little
bubbles and we used snap
to glue the makeup down which I really
like but once in a while I find that it
D gases and I'd start we'd start getting
like little bubbles and and especially
on the tip of his nose and Pete would go
in with a brush and just kind of roll
those little blisters off of his nose
that was a constant thing but Tony was
really good about it you know he he
didn't overexert himself you know if he
didn't have to so he was very very good
about the makeup and and and maintaining
it so that certainly helped quite a bit
I think at another time Howard and Peter
and Martin you mentioned that when
Anthony would sit down in the chair he
didn't move that he was just a rock in
that chair he when we did the time lapse
stuff he just it was kind of weird
because he never he it looked like a
statue he just would not move and we'd
be working on it for an hour and he
would just he was just so knout and just
sit there very you know just how many of
you makeup artists and your stuff is out
there appreciate that okay another
question oh we have one over here hi
Beatrice T Alba I have a question for
Rick and Peter actually your wig work is
just stellar what was your process and
how did you manage to keep those on as
well as you did in the battle scenes and
with all the moisture that you had going
on it's again a case of just going in
all the time when you can because
obviously now in the Newton Newton
format filming they can they can roll
and they can roll and they can roll and
they don't stop and you sit on the
sidelines just sort of closing your eyes
and saying I can't look I can't look I
don't know I'd think that beard is still
on his face or whatever but again I
think you know we found the the process
of and I think it's a process of
actually how you apply I mean we used we
use the glue but it's the process of how
you actually apply it and stick the lace
down that means it'll stay on and I find
you have to be quite brutal with lace
you can't be delicate and fine because
it'll cut
off in two seconds flat especially we're
doing that kind of stuff so it is a case
of actually being very brutal and poised
punching the lace into the skin rather
than try to be delicate and then you
it's it's luck I mean there's nothing
else you you can stick something on so
well and you know it might come off you
don't know if you just cross your
fingers and hope for the best and if it
does come off hope they're not going to
use that one it was on occasion at the
end of a cut that you would find an orc
wearing a dwarf weed that wasn't
supposed to be alright I have a question
for Lisa and and Julie we've heard about
a lot of prep time for Hitchcock we
heard about a lot of prep time for The
Hobbit how did that work out so many
times for films are we don't have prep
time anymore how did that work out for
lamia's they offered me six weeks and I
said that's just ridiculous
so they and without even a crowd
supervisor at that point so eventually I
got eight weeks and I've got a crowd
supervisor and then I had to go to heavy
negotiations about the numbers on my
main team and also dailies because they
of course that they don't know what's
involved and they're trying to save
money and whatever I say you have to
make your case strongly and I got I got
what I wanted so for 4-6 weeks prep did
you already have your actors in or were
you still waiting for many of your
actors to be cast I think it was kind of
50/50 really the the big players were
were in place but then there was a
meanie fourth way through the shoot you
know there was there were new people
coming in continually so it was never
completely cast you know it's just I was
continually the wig makers were seeing
new people while they were shooting kits
and endless showing tails just endless
yep and you mentioned a number of people
that had well I think almost all the
people had teeth yeah and a number of
people had lenses mmm there were
three sets of lenses one on the blind
woman and you had two different sets but
I was sort of quite a tight budget you
know and it's quite expensive to have
these lenses because you have to have
somebody standing by and you know
technician and the lens technician and
so you have to kind of add up where do I
put my money here do I put my money
there you know I was not on it was I
mean the whole movie I think was like
sixty million which was nothing
we're on very small budget so to be very
careful about where I put my money you
know and because of the singing you know
we did people most of the actors did
have teeth because you know obviously
close shots and they were singing so
their mouths are opened wider and more
say than if they'd have been acting all
the time certainly all the principals
had had Leonard we have a question back
here yes this is for Tammy from Peoria
and my granddaughter would like to know
who or what inspired you to get into
hair and makeup well it was I'd always
grown up I didn't realize how much I
loved like sci-fi and makeup and Star
Wars and all that thing but it wasn't
until I was I took a trip to Los Angeles
through Bradley University that I
actually toured K&B effects studios and
and met Howard Berger and and it
actually being in that studio I just
looked around and oh my god I didn't
know these places it actually existed I
didn't know didn't know how or where
what to how to get in so once I saw
Howard studio and the artists that
working there and Howard gave me the
advice to go back to Peoria Graduate
University come back Koller
so that's what he did I kept calling and
calling
he's in the meeting he's on set he's
enemy
finally they did get a show they needed
a lot of grunt workers and so he called
me a day before my birthday and offered
me a job cleaning out molds and sweeping
floors and that's what I started seven
dollars an hour
I know we have a lot of student makeup
artists we always do stupid makeup
artist student here stylist you know
there's a good example you've got to
keep at it and keep at it and and
eventually you wear them down
Tammy wore me down she still wears me
down but but we're just real quick on
that same thing I mean Tammy Tammy's
really an exceptional person you know
and I met her when she was 21 years old
and and now she's women's of lift but uh
it's been really great you know to watch
her grow and Tammy and I have been you
know working hand in hand for for years
and years Larry so she's my right and
left hand but when Hobbit came up she
came to me and said I I'm gonna go do
the Hobbit and I went I think you should
it'll be great and it was the first time
in years I hadn't worked with Tammy and
that's when Peter and I started working
together and and which has been
fantastic as well but I'm just it's cool
because you know we're nominated and
they're nominated and my my best pal
Tammy's nominated so you know however it
goes it goes but it's still very
exciting I get to be on the same the
same you know category with with my best
friend yeah truly blessed there'll be a
mud wrestling match out back after the
show that's right yeah win or lose
Tammy's going down
another question wait Leonard we have
one over here right over here hi I'm you
Joshua I'm saitec student introvert and
I got a question for habit and it's like
I know the movie you should sort of Davo
a CG character same way as a character
so my question is do you have reference
for makeup and hair styling for the
digital dabble or do you take CG
character as pre-visualization before so
how's the interaction process I guess
thank you the CG the CGI characters that
they're for instance like garland so
they're done completely differently
their own way but we did all our actors
we scanned what three of you and three
three prostitute for three processes
processes and the leads then had their
teeth cast and facial stuff all
photographed within like inches may be
many many reference photos yeah exactly
and then they take that to weather then
when they want to digitally put the face
somewhere else or whatever those doubles
digital doubles were were used just you
know of course you can't put the actors
in total way of death you know so
exactly yeah they were quite handy yeah
they come in a vanity I think we have a
question over here
hi yeah um this is for ELISA and Julie I
know LEM is covers a very long time span
from earlier 1800s into like the 1840s
how fun was it to research all the hair
and makeup styles from such a large time
period well I found it before if before
let me aside
I found this comfortably spirits before
so I knew them and I generally keep it
all my research from previous films
which is just saves time so you drag all
that out and it you know it all comes
back it's like
riding a bike you know you got always
that shape but then morphs into that
shape which them but you do it's really
important it's all to do with shape
actually it's very very important to
know what shape makes a period which
then moves into another period then we
come to another period as silhouettes
not so much detail but strengthen and
you have to know which way you're
heading you know you have to know it and
as soon as I walk into the curve and
it's not right I know immediately I go
no no no it needs to go out here up or
down you know across here or it's too
flat there or I just get my fingers in I
can't help myself pull and push if it's
wrong it was quite fun them researching
for the lovely ladies and just finding
out what they would have used for makeup
then and research on the convex and yeah
so yet to take you into her and all the
diseases for the poor and they were
quite a lot there's lots of research
that that's that's I really enjoy that's
one of the best bits because you're
you're also you you're just buzzing yeah
you know you can hardly sleep because
your brain is going into overdrive with
ideas and it's extraordinary how the
brain they'll throw stuff at you oh
that's a really good idea and you got no
idea where that came from but let's use
it you know and then you'll share it
with with the team even before you go to
the director or the artists you know
just roar ideas just come flooding out
on you and and then you'll share it with
the rest of the team and you know I
always invite input from everybody
although I always have right Evita at
the end but you know other people are
much better ideas than I do and you an
idiot if you don't use them so we all
work together really it's a big melting
pot then they artists come in they've
got ideas the director comes in and
he'll go no no no it's all it's
complicated business do you have a team
that you normally try to work with I had
a short list of maybe 20 then we
generally up not all of them but a lot
of them are XP PC and we've all been
trained in the same way
and it works really well another
question I think we've got one way in
the back here I actually do have one
right here all right
hello and congratulations to all of you
for the nominations working on set under
time pressure with directors do you ever
get that they brush your concerns off
and how do you deal with that
seeing that you in the end don't have
final say in what actually ends up on
the screen of your work it's it's always
it's you know it's that thing about sort
of understanding that they are under
pressure to get this done and you have
to stand up at the right time when you
think it's really important and other
times you just have to let it go and
pray because you've got to also remember
that a lot of time they're going to be
looking closely when that when they're
cutting this thing together and if a
moustache is half hanging off and you're
seeing the corner crying you know
they're not going to use the shot or if
they do that is stupid but they're not
going to use a shot so you don't have to
worry too much I mean when it gets finer
and you're really concerned and they're
not probably seeing what you can see you
know they're not see what you can see
you just have to fight your case but
then sometimes you just have to let it
go and there's no point falling out
about it that much
I mean on lamé is there was quite often
we'd have eight cameras running and they
would do the the song from start to
finish yeah so it was long and eight
cameras and within that time you would
see things and you'd think on and you
you actually couldn't do anything about
it because it was the whole duration of
the song you know so when that was quite
scary sometimes I also think it's it
worked it depends on the director you're
working with some directors have
tremendous vision they know exactly what
they want and you respect their opinion
your function there is to ultimately
tell the story and help tell the story
the best way you can and
and facilitate what they want and Howard
and I just finished working on a project
where the director was very specific
about what he wanted we had we had ideas
and you listened to them but ultimately
it's their movie it's and you're there
to give them what they want it's their
dime and just facilitate what they want
so you may have great ideas and and
they'll listen to you and some directors
will listen to your your experience and
your ideas and your designs or whatever
and they have ideas as well and
sometimes the actor has ideas so it's
it's a very collaborative thing it
depends on the movie depends on the
director it depends on the situation
there's there's a really great makeup
artist his name's Dave Dupuis and dave
told me a story that he was on set
touching up and they were rushing and
rushing and rushing him he turned around
and said hey pretend I'm in the lighting
department okay yeah and then he got the
expert on can you discuss the statue
downstairs of Alfred Hitchcock generally
impressive oh thanks yeah that's it that
was done at K&B and and we always do
some display stuff from specific
projects and that's something that a lot
of a lot of people were involved with
you know is based on Richie
alonzo sculpture and and Jeremy Aiello
did the clay press and the Reece cult
and the guys molded it in the mold
apartment and and you know ran the
silicone rich Mayberry painted it and
did the hair Nicky I'm drawing a blank
on Nicky's last name sorry did all the
hair work and and anyhow we wanted to
put together a Hitchcock form and that's
actually the original costume that Tony
wore we were able to pry it out of Fox
archives but when you go down there you
take a look and then the hands are one
of our arm old guys Brian his hands
because they looked very similar to Tony
so we cast his hand like that but yeah
we you know if you ever have the
opportunity to go to K&B there's a lot
of cool display stuff and Greg and I
take great pride in that because it's
just kind of you know after the movies
done you know the read the stuff goes
into storage and rots and falls apart
but we always like to do display stuff
and that's that's the latest display we
just did so
when after this go down and take a look
at everybody's tables because there's
tons of great stuff and then that's down
there as well we've got time for one
more question I have one up here if I
may please my name is Bill Blair and I
want to congratulate all of you I'm a
big big big fan of practical makeup in
this day and age especially what you've
done having worn over 200 special effect
makeup characters in my career in TV and
film and I just want to know
with today's technology and everything
how much are the producers production
and studios maybe pushing you from away
from the practical make up into the CGI
and special visuals we're busy as can be
you know we're lucky very very busy
yeah it's I'd say it's not the issue at
all do you agree yeah absolutely no I
know I mean you one thing also you could
remember is that it's the actor who's
underneath if you had all actors like
all the dwarves that said all what the
actors are just gonna be as they are
and then we'll do it all afterwards the
actor wouldn't be able to play that role
I mean it's not just about what you were
saying but it's about actually working
with the actor and you're uncertain the
directors looking at it they all want to
see they don't want to know what it's
gonna be like you know oh it's just the
guy well we'll do it we'll fix it you
know when we're doing a CGI they want to
see you I don't see if that could ever
happen I have to be honest I agree with
you and I can plus the fact it's
expensive so not everybody has five
hundred million dollars and even the
ones that do have five hundred million
dollars we still use practical make it
uh and and it is it's it's the tides
change you know it's you know Quentin
Tarantino and we work with him he'll say
you know today you're gonna be hero but
tomorrow you can be a bum you know
meaning like today you're a hero you
succeeded but then you mess up tomorrow
and you're a bomb and he's let's you
know it and and it's kind of been that
way like you know in the 80s when make a
special make up was at its zenith you
know at that point if we were heroes and
then Jurassic Park came out and then we
were bombs and then you know this came
it so you know now it's you know you're
working with directors that love it you
know that actually having a
for film and makeup and it's not the
let's use the new tool which is really
great and it's a huge combination to
what we all do and you saw it in all
these movies is it you know there's make
there's there's practical makeup
although I'm trying to come up with and
like tangible makeup or something
because practical seems like I don't
know it's I don't know if like that word
but but anyhow and in a combination of
visual effects and and we're all you
know we all have to work under the same
constrictions and limitation set forth
by production and so you know we work
together as a team so when I do a film
and there's visual effects involved we
work hand in hand with VFX and we'll do
things that they can't do or and and
vice versa so in my opinion that the VFX
doesn't CGI doesn't take a bite out of
what we do it enhances it and it
encourages as filmmakers
to continue to make movies that require
that and and obviously we're all good at
our jobs and it's really just another
tool yeah it's a tool and sometimes it's
a matter of safety you can if you can
replace or make a situation safe or a
scene safer for an actor and replace him
with something that's digital it works
or I'll say removal then then it's it's
a viable alternative but it's it's just
another tool like anything else and and
smart filmmakers will realize that
instead of saying well we'll do it all
digitally well it doesn't really work
that way there's good digital as bad
digital dislike there's good makeup in
this bad makeup